tough man I saw Andrew doing uh an
interview and then he was they were
having um one of these guys on and he
was like my brain my brain it was like
they're infecting me
um I use the term minor attractive
person or map uh in the title and
throughout the book for multiple reasons
um first of all because I think it's
important to use terminology for groups
of that group want others to use for
that
um and math advocacy groups like before
you act online um have advocated for
this election programming they're trying
to put it in my brain for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms this is Haram
Haram send her to Saudi let her repeat
this Quran we need the will of God we
need Allah listen I'm ready and you see
that um it's it's really he just really
beautifully explained it in in his
humorous way
and just back to this it's interesting
because I also Drake an interview he was
talking about